it is one of the most dangerous places
on Earth but that didn't stop Russia
pouring troops and tanks into the
Chernobyl exclusion Zone at the start of
the war patrolling the site of the 1986
nuclear disaster while infantry we're
now told dug in literally in the
poisoned Earth nearby
there were quite a lot of trenches and
they were digging trenches in many
different places but I understand that
the most dangerous place was the Redwood
because that's where nuclear waste is
buried people visiting Chernobyl like we
did before the war are told to touch
nothing let alone dig making matters
worse so ukrainians the Russian soldiers
were given out of date radiation
monitoring equipment
whether it is ridiculous whether it is
foolish a hundred percent uh it's
ridiculous because we know that they
were not prepared if they were given had
been given clear guidelines so they
probably wouldn't have ended up being
exposed to radiation since chernobyl's
reactor exploded in 1986 access to the
area has been tightly controlled but
ukrainians say thousands of Russian
military vehicles rolled through here
picking up contaminated soil dug up by
the soldiers we are talking about 30 to
60 kilometers around the Chernobyl
station and that area is heavily
contaminated in this one location in in
five days
ten thousand Russian Vehicles crossed
this this point on their way out from
Ukraine into Belarus contamination could
have been carried into Kiev Belarus and
Russia chernobyl's poisonous Legacy
buried for decades Unearthed and
potentially dispersed far and wide
Dominic wagorn Sky News La Viv